voilà y'a gens mal d'existence
bien jean hugues anglade donc ses vues
voilà holy dis bonjour alors n'impose
pas l'auto vie parce que elle mange pas
de viande pas de quoi sont pas neuves
pas de rien donc évidemment non et j'ai
de la famille pour l'honnête à parce que
les polonais sont un peu pâlot sont pas
très bons ah oui ça c'est vrai des
polonais en même temps et laurent baffie
que vous connaissez jean-marie je ne le
connais pas mais formidable j'ai entendu
parler de votre travail c'est bien
qu'ils jouent du ménage
ce moment oui sinon je dis aux
téléspectateurs soit la peine de
réserver ses pleins jusqu'en 2004 donc
c'est pas la peine d'aller faire la
queue sous la pluie c'est pas en 2004
bien didier gustin bonsoir alors vous
faites un nouveau spectacle qui est mise
en scène et co écrit par jean marie
bigard voilà ce une bonne idée à maladie
alors c'est comment faire
c'est que même l'archevêque de paris l'a
fait quand même
même le pape chez lui quand il ya il à
dz un des gens qui disent à 100% gustin
bon sens et ent % est à n être nom ne
dit rien des dida au palais des glaces
et 1
pourquoi ce titre parce que moi je moi
je m'attaque la tête même si rien parce
que didier gustin joue le régisseur qui
arrive donc sur scène au début du
spectacle et qui annonce que évidemment
gustin n'est pas là et qui va faire
patienter voilà est donc en fait tout le
spectacle vous faites le régisseur qui
fait patienter
oui c'est même c'est même beaucoup plus
riche que ça l'idée c'est que ça permet
aux régisseurs de didier donc le petit
jean claude ça lui permet de se ficher
dessus tout seul c'est à dire de dire si
encore ils avaient si encore il avait du
talent et pour arriver en retard et
surtout c'est un spectacle ça c'est une
grande première qui explique qu'un
imitateur n'est rien sans les gens qui
limite ça c'est la première chose et ça
permet de faire au niveau de la mise en
scène de faire de faire jouer la porte
des morts la porte des vivants la porte
des comics et et didier ben il est que
si je suis allé ce soir dans la salle
avant l'avenir à l'émission j'ai eu
l'impression de rentrer dans un bain
chaud témoins les gens étaient bien et
il ya la sortie m'ont dit bravo à moi
j'ai rien fait c'est lui qui est gay
mais c'est vraiment un bonheur parce que
parce que
il faut y aller ouais vous faites à will
survive avec la voix d'yves montand
petits montants ça fait quoi en fait il
dit dans le spectacle qui chante très
bien l'anglais et il envoie une musique
bien renvoi mais plutôt tiens oui mais
moi [ __ ] de de regret ouais à lui sera
airparif et a une fiche de fresnes à
wissous pétrifié petites et quant à lui
serait amusé sûrs
normalement
le stage nous a bénis coûter